[Musique]
bonjour Hélène à la une de la presse ce
matin la victoire au législative donc en
Italie de cette coalition des droites
emmenée par la poste fasciste Georgia
Meloni les Talia va Hadès l'Italie passa
à droite et choisi Giorgia Meloni
annonce ce matin la Stampa en présentant
en Fratelli Italia le parti de Georgia
Meloni comme la première formation
politique italienne ce qu'il a place
vous l'avez dit en position d'ultra
favorite pour accéder à la présidence du
Conseil italien avec plus de 24% des
voix mélodie prend l'Italie la
républicain pour la République à cette
victoire change l'histoire du pays avec
un centre gauche qui je le cite paye
cette division et son incapacité à unir
ses forces y compris face à l'abordage
lancé par l'extrême droite italienne
proche de la droite populiste libellule
le quotidien de Milan exulte
littéralement liberi libre s'exclame le
journal en s'a d'ailleurs directement à
Mélodie maintenant c'est ton tour c'est
à toi de jouer de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier politique il manifeste au
quotidien communiste montre la patronne
de Fratelli Italia brattendu dans un
geste rappelant le salut fasciste le ton
est au défi à Noé à nous le journal
parle d'un tremblement de terre
politique sur fond d'abstention
historique et accuse lui aussi les
forces de gauche de portée je cite
toujours la grave est lourde
responsabilité de n'avoir même pas
essayé de se battre contre l'extrême
droite on le disait avant même ces
résultats qui étaient attendus en
s'inquiète du côté de Bruxelles quelle
réaction du côté de la presse européenne
mais l'Italie se coulera avec une
victoire historique de l'extrême droite
l'avant Guardi au quotidien catalan
confirme que Georgia mélony pourrait
devenir la nouvelle présidente du
Conseil italien ce qui serait d'ailleurs
une première dans l'histoire politique
de l'Italie selon El Pais seule la
victoire de mélodie aurait effectivement
était largement anticipée au niveau
européen et le journal espagnol assure
que Bruxelles s'est préparé à je cite
contenir une éventuelle attaque de
l'extrême droite en Italie lieu ayant
déjà prévenu quel dispose d'instruments
pour répondre à une éventuelle érosion
du projet européen comme elle l'a déjà
fait d'ailleurs avec la Hongrie et la
Pologne au Royaume-Uni de Financial
Times juge toutefois improbable une
dérive vers l'extrémisme de l'Italie
dans la mesure où Meloni a remporté ses
élections sur une plateforme
nationaliste et conservatrice bien plus
proche en réalité des formules qui ont
fait le succès des coalitions de
Berlusconi dans le passé que de celle du
mouvement social italien qui est le
parti néo fasciste dont sont issus les
Fratelli d'Italia s'agissant précisément
de ses alliés de Georgia Meloni de
Guardian estime que les rivalités
internes pourraient rapidement menacer
la stabilité de sa coalition le journal
rappelle notamment les amabilités de
Matteo Salvini à l'égard de Giorgia
Meloni décrite par le patron de la Ligue
comme une emmerdeuse je le cite très
élégant en Iran cette fois le Président
Ibrahim a appelé ce weekend les forces
de l'ordre à agir fermement contre je
cite ceux qui portent atteinte à la
sécurité et la paix du pays et du peuple
alors que vous l'avez montré à les
manifestants manifestent depuis 9 jours
maintenant la presse officielle continue
d'ignorer la colère provoquée par la
mort de Marsa mini comme elle tente de
taire la répression préférant consacrer
c'est une aux manifestations de soutien
orchestrés par le régime comme cette Une
du journal iron news faisant état de
full immense je cite descendu dans les
rues de Téhéran pour dénoncer les actes
de violence meurtrières et la
profanation de lieu sacrés islamiques
par les ametiers passer sous silence on
l'entend on le voit par la presse
officielle les manifestations en cours
en Iran trouvent en revanche un très
large écho dans la internationale
notamment française avec cet hommage de
libération aux iranienne en perçant et
ce titre femme vit liberté trois mots
Oni par la République islamique les
Iraniennes sont aux avant-post on l'a vu
depuis maintenant plusieurs jours elles
sont aux avant-postes de cette
contestation et plusieurs d'entre elles
l'ont payé de leur vie parmi elles il y
a à Disney 20 ans à peine à battu la
semaine dernière alors qu'elle
manifestait la tête nue découverte dans
la ville de carrages c'est pas loin de
Téhéran les femmes diront auxquelles
rentrent aussi hommage le dessinateur
menton morlons dont le dessin est publié
par The Times pas mal il montre l'une de
ses manifestantes un se coupant les
cheveux au nez à la barbe comme on dit
des mots là un mot à présent c'est
référendum ils sont toujours en cours
jusqu'à demain dans les quatre régions
ukrainiennes placées sous contrôle de
Moscou région dans les habitants doivent
se prononcer donc sur leur rattachement
à la Fédération de Russie cette parodie
se simulacre ces de référendum sont
associés par le journal France à la
croix à la BD vous devez la connaître
Tintin au pays des soviettes ou des
commissaires politiques chargés
d'organiser les élections mettent en
joues des électeurs et demandent que
ceux qui s'opposent à cette liste lèvent
la main qui donc se déclare contre cette
liste le vernis démocratique badigeonné
par le Kremlin ne trompe personne pas
même les Russes qui continuent à fuir
l'appel à la mobilisation partielle des
hommes en âge de combattre sur le front
ukrainien cette réalité fait la une ce
matin du journal néerlandais de
folkrante qui précise que des centaines
de ces hommes ont pris notamment la
direction de la Géorgie qui est une
ancienne république soviétique qui
n'exigent pas de visa pour les ressortir
les ressortissements Russes
qui laissent passer pour l'instant
moyennant quelques billets pour
l'instant en tout cas et la noce quitte
pas là dessus mais avant de vous dire à
tout à l'heure Damien histoire de vous
changer un peu les idées je vous propose
de jeter un stylo Guardian qui fait état
d'un avis scientifique ma foi assez sur
maintenant l'affirmation par un groupe
d'experts qu'il vaudrait mieux
finalement elle explorée la planète
Vénus plutôt que la planète Mars et
pourquoi donc me barrer vous mais oui
parce qu'en dépit sa surface
suffisamment chaude pour faire fondre le
plomb sa pression atmosphérique
écrasante et ses nuages d'acide
sulfurique et bien la planète Vénus sur
laquelle on pourra pas se poser donc ça
paraît évident mais qu'on pourra
contempler d'en haut et notamment
beaucoup plus proche de nous avec un
élève taux réalisable en un an contre
trois tout de même pour la planète Mars
ce qui part tant de pénurie énergétique
peut-être un argument non négligeable
pour se poser en revanche merci beaucoup
Hélène pour cette revue de presse